this week is not going to be the
sweeping victory for gay rights that I
think that many many many gay rights
advocates and supporters hoped for
however i think the Defense of Marriage
Act which does directly harm gay couples
by depriving them of various marriage
benefits and protections and so forth
that's that's in troubled so that's that
stuff definitely a win for gay rights
there hello I'm Catherine manga award
for reason TV and I'm here today with
Damon root hi Damon I as our supreme
court reporter you were on the scene for
day two of the gay marriage extravaganza
at the court this week tell us a little
bit about what today's case was today's
case was the Defense of Marriage Act
section 3 which says that the federal
government cannot recognize legal
same-sex unions same-sex unions that are
legal under state law will not be
recognized by the federal government so
this was being challenged as a violation
of the Equal Protection Clause ready
Protection component of the Fifth
Amendment to the Constitution as well as
being challenged as a sort of an
overreach of violation of federalism
scheme federal powers and so yesterday
and the prop 8 arguments there was there
was there was not much of a didn't seem
to be much of an appetite among the
justices to reach the constitutional
question and really give a chord a big
vote in favor of gay rights or gay
marriage today was a very different tone
in court and what we saw was with
several justices like as particularly
Justice Anthony Kennedy who is is the
author of previous gay rights opinions
really ready to strike down the Defense
of Marriage Act section 3 as an
overreach of federal power and and many
of the liberal justices ready to go
along with them so read the tea leaves
for us with a little bit of arbitrage
between the two cases what what do you
think the landscape could look like you
know given what you've seen about how
the justices reacted yesterday and today
I'm going forward well I think the what
we can see what we can probably going to
see what the prop 8 case is is a very
complicated ruling that largely you know
sort of dodges or kicks back the
constitutional question to the lower
courts so it's it's sort of unclear
they're going to be gay marriage in
California maybe maybe prop adel will go
down maybe property it will stay
it's just going to be relitigate 'add so
that that's there's uncertainty there
whereas with the Defense of Marriage Act
case I think it's much more likely that
that that that law is going to go down
now there's also these sort of
jurisdictional questions about the
Defense of Marriage Act and this stems
from the Obama administration's position
which a year ago the Obama said well I
believe this law is unconstitutional so
I we're no longer going to defend it in
court however we are going to enforce
the law and and specifically in this
case what that means is this woman Edith
Windsor who's who has the same-sex
spouse of 40 years her spouse dies Edith
Windsor has to pay nearly four hundred
thousand dollars in taxes to the federal
government that she if DOMA was not in
effect she would not have to pay so she
suffered a real injury the White House
is saying well we're not going to defend
the law court but we're going to take
your money and that was that was a
position that did not go over well with
babe by my count most of the justices
liberal and conservative like who really
thought the abomination had put the
court in just a pickle you know if you
know justice Chief Justice Roberts said
something like you know that the the
White House should have the courage of
its convictions if the ACA law is
unconstitutional should just not be
defending it so assuming that the court
settles on this jurisdictional matter i
think the Defense of Marriage Act is in
trouble so the court was kind of hard on
presidents today right because in
addition to this implied critique of
Obama there was also briefly the
question of whether or not Bill Clinton
who of course signed the Defense of
Marriage Act into law might might be a
bigot and whether that would have
bearing on the standing you know the
sort of the specter of Bubba Clinton was
it was kind of hovering over the court
he was not named but you know one of the
questions is if if the Defense of
Marriage Act was was passed basically to
express anti-gay animus or bigotry then
it would be unconstitutional presumably
under the Equal Protection component of
Constitution and the Chief Justice who
did not seem to be interested in
striking down DOMA at all he was
pressing those who are against the law
to really say are you saying that the
president and the 84 senators who signed
this law that they you know they were
they had they were expressing bigotry
and you know the Solicitor General he
you know he was not ready to admit to
that but there was this clear
implication that if you're saying that
that this law is based in anti-gay
animus then the president who signed it
you know as guilty of that so very quick
rack up wrap up this week good for the
gays bad for the gays good for freedom
bad for freedom go it was it was this
week is not going to be the sweeping
victory for gay rights that I think that
many many many gay rights advocates and
supporters hoped for I don't think we're
going to see a 50-state solution gay
marriage legal in 50 states i think the
supreme court made it clear including
liberal justices like like Sotomayor
that they are just not quite ready to
what do what Anthony Kennedy called
uncharted water so not quite ready to go
go that far however i think the Defense
of Marriage Act which which which does
directly harm gay couples by depriving
them of various marriage benefits and
protections and so forth that's that's
in troubled so that's that stuff
definitely a win for gay rights there
thank you very much Damon thank you
4recent EV i'm katherine manual